foreign
[Music]
welcome to this week's news here you can
learn about all the brand new
developments around your favorite movies
and Series this time around you can
expect new details about the new seasons
of stranger things and House of the
Dragon there is also news regarding
superheroes with the Batman 2 and
Daredevil Born Again moreover there's
information about a couple of shelved
Star Wars projects as well as a new
movie from the alien Universe have fun
watching
for many stranger things season 4 was no
doubt a highlight of the Netflix
franchise many feature like episodes
plenty of action and some scenes that
are already regarded as Classics in the
series story all the more reason for
fans to be pleased that things are
finally continuing with the final season
Hopper actor David Harbor himself was
recently invited to the Middle East film
and Comic-Con to announce that filming
is about to start it's set to happen in
June of 2023 and then the cast around
Millie Bobby Brown Finn wolfhard Sadie
sync and more will be in front of the
camera one last time for The Duffer
Brothers for now at least physically
David Harbor will have it a little
easier than in season four while he
spent most of his time in a Soviet
prison and was allowed to show some
muscle the character is back in his
Native America in season 5 according to
a statement with cheeseburgers included
a planned release date for stranger
things season 5 is currently not known
but many estimate a release date
sometime in 2024. we will of course keep
you up to date with the latest news
about the filming
at least two more years will pass before
the sequel to The successful the Batman
from 2022 can be watched in theaters
until now it was not very clear when the
shooting and thus the busy phase of
production will begin Michael uslin who
was already involved as a producer in
the previous film has now announced the
long-awaited start of shooting for the
Batman part 2. up to now we only knew
that it would begin sometime this year
now it's clear that Robert Pattinson
will be back in front of the camera as
The Dark Knight in November so although
filming may not be starting very early
at least there is now a set date that
fans can look forward to until then
there is bound to be plenty of
information about who will be returning
or joining the cast alongside Pattinson
recently giant freaking robot reported
that the well-known district attorney
Harvey Dent will play a part in the
upcoming film it is said that no actor
has been found for the role of the
mysterious character yet but since he
has already been played by Billy D
Williams Tommy Lee Jones and Aaron
Eckhart it can be assumed that a new
actor will be cast this time as well
until the start of shooting it remains
exciting to see which familiar
characters will appear in the Batman
part 2. in addition to the latest news
on the film there are fresh images of
the Penguin series which is supposed to
draw a line between the Batman and its
sequel featured as none other than fan
favorite Colin Farrell himself who
received much praise for his portrayal
of the gangster boss in the Batman the
leaked images show the 46 year old actor
on set which makes these the first shots
of the penguin since the feature film
the series is scheduled to start next
year so there will be plenty of time for
marketing the Batman 2.
so far the so-called Defenders
consisting of Luke Cage Daredevil
Jessica Jones and Iron Fist could be
seen in several series on Netflix
however after Disney rejected a further
renewal of the rights transfer the film
rights were returned to the parent
company last year this was quickly
followed by various announcements of
In-House projects for the Defenders
including the plan series Daredevil born
again this week The Hollywood Reporter
revealed that the company is planning to
bring back a beloved hero from the
Netflix days we are talking about John
Bernthal who has had two of his own
Seasons as The Punisher after his whole
family was murdered he plans to take
revenge on the gangs that caused it
although the reviews for the Netflix
series were not really impressive it
still found a noteworthy following which
has been waiting for new content since
the official cancellation in 2019 even
though there is no official confirmation
from Marvel yet the current news is
deemed credible which is why a statement
is expected to be made very soon in
addition to bird ball and lead actor
Charlie Cox Daredevil born again will
also Mark the return of Vincent de
andreo as Kingpin having already
appeared in the Hawkeye series Cox has
previously appeared in Spider-Man no way
home and She-Hulk disappointingly for
fans of the Netflix series Daredevil his
Sidekicks Elven Henson and Deborah Ann
Woll are not set to come back as foggy
Nelson and Karen Page the time frame
until you can see Daredevil born again
on Disney plus will drag on at least
until summer 2024 after a release in
Spring of 2024 has already been
considered unrealistic this is also due
to the fact that Daredevil born again
will be based on the series echo which
is also not scheduled for release until
2024 and will include appearances by Cox
and deontrio anyway the shooting of
Daredevil Born Again started a few days
ago so we can look forward to further
news soon
with alien Covenant a feature film for
the popular alien franchise was last
released six years ago after the film
was not really well received and the
predecessor Prometheus also fell short
of expectations the time has long since
come for a reboot of the film series
this is finally going to happen at 20th
Century Studios with evil dead and don't
breathe director Fede Alvarez who
already has notable experience in the
horror genre he has been overseeing the
filming of what is officially the fifth
alien movie since March 9th one that is
not a prequel nor a crossover with a
much younger cast than before according
to an article by The Hollywood Reporter
the upcoming film with the working title
alien Romulus will focus on a group of
young people living in a distant colony
who find themselves in a fight for
survival with the eponymous alien a
total of five new cast members have been
announced with mayor of East Town
actress Kaylee spaney taking the lead
role in addition to actors Spike Fern
and Eileen Wu we will also see industry
star David Johnson Transformer as the
last night star Isabella Merced and
Archie Renault best known from Shadow
and bone on screen a participation of
Sigourney Weaver as Alan Ripley seems
rather unlikely at this point 2024 seems
to be a realistic time frame for the
theatrical release of alien 5 based on
the current filming start but official
information is still missing in parallel
to the feature film an Alien series by
the showrunner of Fargo Noah Holly is
also in the works we can therefore look
forward to more news about the franchise
one of the highlights of the hit series
Game of Thrones was certainly the
appearance of dragons as a result HBO
added the spin-off House of the Dragon
in 2022 which focused even more on the
fantasy creatures new information about
season 2 now makes fans Hearts flutter
as deadline recently reported showrunner
Ryan condal spoke out and announced that
there will be five new dragons in the
next House of the Dragon season the
inspiration for this decision came when
the author of the original novel Fire
and Blood George R.R Martin expressed
his excitement about the creative
realization of the powerful creatures
for him the dragons in the series Game
of Thrones were all pretty much the same
in House of the Dragon however they had
distinct personalities and simply came
alive however producer kondal held back
with further news about season two all
that is known at the moment is that two
new characters named blood and cheese
will be added who at least in the
original book support Queen renera's
Revenge apart from that however Martin's
work continues only to serve as an
outline for the series rather
independent plot at this point the
finale of House of the Dragons season 2
is still being written which probably
won't see the light of day until 2024.
when Star Wars the rise of Skywalker was
released in 2019 many fans were
expecting more despite grossing more
than one billion dollars Star Wars
Episode 9 was not quite a huge success
with critical audiences as we learned
this week some upcoming projects have
now been scrapped entirely it remains
uncertain what Disney's further schedule
will look like after the end of the
Skywalker Saga as variety reports two
planned Star Wars movies have been
shelved the Rogue Squadron movie by
Patty Jenkins and an unknown movie by
Kevin feige are affected both expressed
interest in the past in directing a
movie of the world famous franchise
however this will now no longer be the
case Jenkinson's movie was officially
announced in late 2020 and should have
premiered at the end of the year the
focus would likely have been Skywalker
and his X-Wing Attack Force at the end
of 2022 Jenkins tweeted that she still
was working on the project but didn't
know how likely it was to come to
fruition there was considerably less
information about the film by Marvel
Master remind Kevin feige neither title
story nor cast were known about the
project which is probably why it never
made it past an early production stage
only the screenwriter Michael Waldron
was known though he now has his hands
full with Loki season 2 and Avengers
Secret Wars let alone MCU boss feige who
is very busy as well the movie is
probably not completely off the table
yet but we shouldn't get our hopes up in
the next few years things are looking
better for the potential next film in
the Star Wars series this one is by Thor
love and thunder director taika waititi
and is said to be progressing
comparatively well the script has not
been finalized yet but they are at least
working on it in addition we can look
forward to ITT not only working behind
the camera but also in front of it since
the 47 year old will also play A Part as
an actor it is also a possibility that a
film by Charmaine Obed chenoy will be
released first the Miss Marvel director
is slated to direct a Star Wars film as
well while World War Z writer Damon
Lindelof and counterpart writer Justin
Britt Gibson are in charge to the script
so despite the cancellations of two
films there's definitely still a lot
going on behind the scenes of Star Wars
and we are looking forward to more news
about the franchise's next feature film
which news did you find most interesting
this week and do you have any other
information that didn't make it into our
video feel free to share them with the
others in the comments and for those of
you who want to watch more content on
our Channel check out our movie previews
for The Equalizer 3 and the Meg 2 the
trench thanks for watching and see you
next week for more Weekly News
[Music]
thank you